charles belimo bonjour bonjour que c'est
une pépite bonjour la monuc vous êtes
candidat aux élections législatives vous
vous présentez dans le centre sur la
liste du rassemblement national
alors pourquoi êtes vous candidat à ce
scrutin oui disons que c'est le fruit
d'une longue réflexion donc nous avions
constaté perso je dis nous parce que je
parle lui au nom du réseau national de
martinique nous avons constaté que
depuis mais c'est zéro qu'il ya une
certaine
un oubli de la part des des politiques
de notre pays donc nous constatons que
la
prostate que le pays est à cahill le
keirin n'avance pas ça donc
à plusieurs décisions prises qui sont
toujours les décisions prises à
l'encontre de la société martiniquaise
donc c'est pour cela que nous avons pris
la décision en nous présentant cette
fois ci à cette élection de 2000 2022
alors ce concernant les projets
prioritaires que vous souhaitez défendre
si vous êtes élu à l'assemblée nationale
pour le territoire martinique
bon je vais vous citer trois puisque la
liste serait trop longue moi en disant
que je m'engage à assurer à la
population la première des libertés qui
s est la sécurité en augmentant les
effectifs de police et de gendarmerie
je ferai en sorte que les watts crête
soit obtenue à port tudy à 40 annuités
pour toutes les personnes qui ont
commencé à travailler très tôt et pour
avoir un minimum de
62 ans et non à 65 ans comme le propose
le président macron est beau aussi en
augmentant leur pouvoir d'achat du du
peuple martiniquais non pas en
augmentant systématiquement le smic
comme le propose d'autres candidats par
exemple j'en ai bien au chaud mais en
baissant les taxes sur l'énergie c'est à
dire leur carburant c'est-à-dire
l'électricité et le gaz
donc et aussi nous allons glisser les
époux alors concernant la
circonscription dans laquelle vous vous
présenter en l'occurrence le centre
quels seront vos deux ou trois priorités
principales dont 10 dans ma
circonscription d'oak nous avions
trinité et l'euro bien qu'il faut face à
aux halles s'agace qui devient un
véritable une problématique que jusqu'à
présent aucune solution n'a été trouvée
par nos élus et là incapables députés je
ne demanderai pas qu'on en voit encore
de la rocha mais trouver des solutions
trouvait du matériel pour qu'une bonne
fois pour toutes que nous éditons le
problème des sargasses sous tous les
secteurs qui nous tire ou bien où ça
c'est vraiment un grand désagrément avez
vous d'autres priorités pour la
circonscription du centre atlantique le
baril a il faut dire que c'est un
territoire agricole donc aussi de quoi
nous avons le gone qui en grand bastion
de la culture en martinique nous allons
travailler aussi concernant la
chlordécone faut essayer de
haut niveau de point au niveau de la
terre donc il ya ceux pour lui de
trouver des solutions voilà donc ça et
nous avions pour ça au niveau il ya
seulement eu besoin de seulement
national nous avions aussi des
scientifiques qui travaillent avec nous
auprès de qui nous allons
les interroger pour savoir vraiment de
pour nous aider à trouver une solution
pour crète pour éradiquer ce problème
alors dernière question qu'avez-vous à
rajouter à dire aux électeurs bon j'en
conviens vidéo et lecture le vote de
l'assemblée nationale est la seule
véritable opposition à la politique
désastreuse des manuels mâcon je tiens à
dire mon unique et de ne plus se laisser
berner par les politiciens pourtant
sioniste qui est distante unique ni les
marchands d'illusions qui sévissent
depuis des années et en plus c'est que
ces gens-là ne pense uniquement qu'à
leurs propres intérêts donc et au niveau
des élections ces gens là ne sont que
les valets du président macron charles
belimo merci à vous
[Musique]